[Musica]
Immagino la mia vita come un bellissimo
vaso un bellissimo vaso fatto di colori
dove Dentro c'è la mia spontaneità la
mia voglia di vivere
immagino dentro questo vaso le mie
passioni
la mia passione grandissima per la
pallavolo
iniziata sette anni perché guardavo Mila
e Shiro e quindi chi sei i miei genitori
di iniziare a praticare questa
disciplina
immagino questo vaso con all'interno la
mia passione per le materie giuridiche
fin da bambina volevo fare il
commissario di polizia
immagino dentro questo vaso la mia
voglia di aiutare sempre gli altri a 18
anni appena diventata maggiorenne mi
scrissi in un'associazione del
territorio che supporta i malati quindi
ho iniziato poi a fare assistenza al 118
come volontaria e ho dedicato 7 anni
della mia vita in ambulanza con anziani
persone con disabilità trasportava i
pazienti dalle case di riposo a casa o
ancora peggio da casa in casa di riposo
ho avuto la fortuna di parlare e
conoscere persone in situazioni
veramente complesse che mi hanno
arricchita tantissimo e spesso mi hanno
salutata con un sorriso che mi è rimasto
dentro questa questo vaso con
all'interno quello che vi ho appena
detto e si è rotto si è rotto
completamente nel 2013
a causa di una malattia congenita rara e
è successo quello che io chiamo un
terremoto quel momento improvviso che se
chiudete gli occhi immaginate tutto che
trema si rompe tutto questo è quello che
mi è accaduto
ed è iniziato tutto mentre stavo
mangiando ho cominciato a avere delle
crisi epilettiche e quindi oltre le
crisi le crisi quelle famose che
Conoscete tutti perché magari avete
visto nei film
Io ho cominciato a vedere cose che non
esistevano si chiamano crisi proprio
visive mi sono spaventata lì Poi in
realtà io sono svenuta mi sono ritrovata
in ospedale e da quel momento da quel
primo maggio 2013
ogni pezzo della mia vita è finito a
terra è rimasto un unico pezzo questo io
dovevo ripartire da quell'unico pazzo da
quell'unico pezzo tra un ricovero e
l'altro dal capire chi ero e cosa potevo
fare dalla mia vita mi sono ritrovata
con un pezzo per terra che era il mio
sogno di continuare
la mia passione per la pallavolo ho
ritrovato per terra quel pezzo che
diceva che non potevo più fare il
commissario di polizia che non potevo
più essere la Nadia che ero prima che
non potevo più in realtà adesso vi
faccio ridere indossare il tacco 12 per
quale motivo perché ero molto molto
amante dei tacchi
in realtà adesso è molto complesso
a metterli perché altrimenti
Insomma non è facile Ecco però
ripartire da questo e in tante notti
tanti veramente vi dico tante notti in
cui mi chiedevo perché a me
perché a me è una domanda che ti
ti travolge perché non sai darti una
spiegazione ti dici Sono una brava
ragazza ho dedicato tanti anni della mia
vita agli altri non ho mai fatto del
male a nessuno o hai dei sogni o degli
obiettivi sono giovani perché a me
in realtà la risposta non arriva Io non
sono qui per darvi una risposta perché
non esiste non c'è la risposta per chi
ama è così e basta e
ripartendo da quell'unico pezzo a parte
nella vera la fortuna di avere una
bellissima famiglia tantissimi amici che
mi vogliono bene e qualcuno anche che
non si è fatto più sentire
in realtà
consapevolezza che ho preso Poi col
tempo non perché non mi volessero bene
Semplicemente perché non sapevano come
reagire A volte quando capita un lutto
non sappiamo cosa dire quando capita
questo non sappiamo cosa dire abbiamo
paura di dire la cosa sbagliata
inizialmente c'erano rimasta male Poi
però ho capito che in realtà erano
persone che non sapevano come affrontare
la cosa per paura di ferirmi
ma vi dicevo ancora sempre questo unico
pezzo non mi bastava l'amore Degli altri
non mi bastava l'amore per me stessa
perché forse in quel momento Anzi tolgo
il forse io in quel momento non mi amavo
abbastanza in realtà lo vedevo come un
fallimento fallimento personale anche
per quale motivo
per me era un lutto era un fallimento
nel non poter più fare le cose di prima
e ma un lutto gravissimo perché la Nadia
di prima non c'era più
e non avevo perso solo un caro Io avevo
perso me Io non esistevo più perché
Nadia ormai era a pezzi e quindi
la cosa che mi ha cambiato la vita è
stata la psicoterapia fatto un anno e
mezzo di psicoterapia per capire perché
ho capito in realtà che io stavo
sprofondando ho capito che
dovevo decidere di farmi aiutare da un
professionista e quindi ho iniziato a
fare psicoterapia E lì ho capito che io
non ero diversa lo so state pensando Ma
sì che è diverso non vedi in carrozzina
No in realtà io non sono diversa io sono
differente
tutti noi siamo differenti
C'è chi ha qualche chilo in più C'è chi
qualche chilo in meno c'è chi cammina
magari mezza storto c'è chi cammina con
la carrozzina c'è chi vede bene e chi
non vede bene C'è chi si sente bene c'è
chi non si sente bene Ah in realtà la
perfezione non esiste sfiderai a trovare
qualcuno di voi che sia perfetto Non
esiste Io sono differente faccio le cose
che facevo prima in maniera differente
Questa è una consapevolezza che ho preso
grazie al supporto della psicoterapia e
da lì Grazie ovviamente anche l'aiuto di
tanti amici familiari del mio compagno
che mi è stato accanto nonostante tutto
Ho costituito la prima squadra di
sitting Volley in Veneto
e sitting volley a pallavolo paralimpica
si gioca da seduti per terra Quindi
possono praticarla tutti atleti con
disabilità e atleti senza disabilità se
tutti uguali perché alla fine io seduta
per terra voi la mia disabilità non la
vedete siamo uguali quindi
costituita questa prima squadra di
sitting Volley ho avuto l'onore e la
fortuna che un mio video fosse visto
dalla selezione nazionale del sitting
Volley che stava proprio costituendo la
prima nazionale femminile di sitting
volley
il 17 aprile
del 2015
ero a Roma a Roma con altre otto ragazze
che come me avevano le loro esperienze
chi nata con una disabilità chi Con una
disabilità
avvenuta con gli anni E da lì è partito
un percorso
indimenticabile Nel senso che ho avuto
la fortuna e l'onore non solo di
indossare la maglia azzurra che vi posso
garantire a una mozione che ti travolge
cantare l'inno prima di una partita è
qualcosa di incredibile Perché
rappresenti l'Italia nel mondo in Cina
in Corea Budapest in Italia stessa
quando abbiamo fatto tornare
internazionale anche qui in Italia e in
casa ovviamente si gioca ancora più
volentieri perché abbiamo il nostro tifo
la nazionale mi ha dato tantissimo ma
non solo a livello agonistico quindi mi
sono divertita tantissimo nel giocare ma
mi ha dato tantissimo nelle persone cosa
intendo dire quando si va e tornai
internazionali si conoscono tantissime
persone atleti di tutti i paesi si
conoscono persone di posti piccolissimi
in cui non saresti mai andata perché
dice Ok mi faccio le ferie lì perché c'è
questo ma in realtà nessuno penserebbe
di andare a rotonda magari qualcuno di
voi non sa neanche dove sia rotonda
rotonda un bellissimo posto che vi
invito a guardare su internet Dov'è dove
io ho conosciuto persone meravigliose Ma
non solo lì in tutta Italia in tutto il
mondo le persone mi hanno dato qualcosa
di incredibile
e quindi ve lo posso dire quel pezzo che
c'era per terra che riguardava la
pallavolo quando mi ero detta tu non
puoi più giocare a pallavolo così non è
stato mi sono ripresa il mio pezzo e
l'ho unito a quello quel poco che era
rimasto di me Grazie al sitting volley
però mancavano altri pezzi e io quando è
successo studiavo all'università
studiavo giurisprudenza Perché volevo
diventare come servi polizia e quindi
ad un certo punto dopo tante
soddisfazioni a livello agonistico con
la nazionale ho deciso di riprendere gli
studi e di dire a me stessa che potevo
farcela Mi sono laureata in Diritto
dell'Economia e il 21 di ottobre e il 22
di ottobre mi sono iscritta al
giurisprudenza che era la facoltà che
stavo cercando di concludere quando è
arrivato questo Padova come università
In Diritto dell'Economia mi ha dato
tantissimo e non non bisogna
assolutamente Sottovalutare l'importanza
universitaria per chi ha disabilità per
chi non ha disabilità il mondo
universitario è un mondo che ti apre gli
occhi ti apre gli occhi
nel soprattutto nel rispetto verso te
stesso e gli altri che siano studi
giuridici umanistici quello che volete
e giurisprudenza presso l'Università
degli Studi di Ferrara mi sta dando
tanto anche quella però
Questo pazzo me lo sono ripresa riguardo
agli studi
c'è un altro pezzo che era finito lì per
terra che era quello del volontariato e
vi ho detto che facevo la volontaria in
ambulanza e non potevo più rifare la
volontaria in ambulanza ho deciso di
fare una sfida come stessa però mi era
stato proposto di scrivere un libro per
bambini e un libro sulla mia storia e mi
sono rifiutata e ho deciso di scrivere
un libro per bambini
raccontando la storia di Sofia e una
Sofia Io amo il nome Sofia quindi una
Nadia un po' diversa e questo libro che
si chiama ruote alate tutto il devoluto
va nell'acquisto di carrozzine sportive
magari qualcuno non lo sa però le
carrozzine per il movimento l'autonomia
sono passate dal sistema sanitario
nazionale quelle sportive no Ve le
dovete pagare molte famiglie non hanno
l'opportunità di potersele pagare
quindi con questo libro in base ai
giovani del territorio che hanno bisogno
al regalo delle carrozzine l'ultima ve
lo dico con grandissimo orgoglio è stata
il 15 di febbraio una carrozzina dal
costo di 9.200 euro ad un ragazzo che ha
la Duchenne una malattia gravissima e
rarissima per me è stata una gioia
assurda dare a Davide questa carrozzina
perché lui ne aveva una che non gli
poteva permettere di muoversi in
autonomia Il costo è alto però
le forze messe a disposizione sono
tantissime Quando fai squadra e io ho
fatto squadra con tutto il territorio e
quando fai squadra i risultati arrivano
gli obiettivi arrivano e questa è una
cosa che mi ha insegnato lo sport avere
dei grandi obiettivi per grandi
risultati però
ci sono altri pezzi lì per terra l'altro
pezzo lì per terra
è il desiderio di diventare mamma
il desiderio di diventare mamma
io fin da bambina volevo diventare mamma
ho cresciuto mia sorella che è qui oggi
e lei è nata Quando io avevo 14 anni
quindi me la portavo in giro mi dicevano
signorina Che bella figliola che c'è No
non è mia figlia è mia sorella e l'ho
cresciuta le cambiavo il pannolino e la
portavo a fare sport ma lei non ama lo
sport Quindi in realtà ha iniziato aveva
le superstizioni quindi suona al
pianoforte conservatorio e così via
volevo diventare mamma ma un desiderio
così grande che
andava oltretutto E beh quel pezzo sono
riuscita ad averlo il 21 aprile del 2020
in pieno lockdown è nato il mio
Francesco Francesco tra poco compie 3
anni ed è la gioia della mia vita e
lo so magari qualcuno si chiede come fa
questa Eh sì ho reso tutta a casa
accessibile non solo a me ma anche alle
sue esigenze Quindi da un fasciatoio
fatto su misura la cucina Era già su
misura in realtà io in casa mia sono
completamente autonoma e quindi
quella gioia che tanto mi porta ogni
giorno che lo guardo e mi dico
Volere potere e quel pezzo dopo pezzo mi
ha permesso Non dico di unire
completamente il vaso perché ci sono
pezzettini che sono rimasti per terra
io non potrò camminare non potrò fare
tante cose che può fare una persona in
piedi ma posso farne tante altre quindi
alcuni pezzi li ho ricostruiti o
completamente Come magari nel condurre a
un programma in RAI e
record oltre l'impossibile esperienze
che spesso nessuno Insomma si aspetta di
poter fare Ho avuto la fortuna anche
quindi di fare veramente cose che
mai avrei potuto fare ogni singolo pezzo
che io Ho unito che mi ha permesso di
ricomporre il mio vaso la mia vita in
maniera differente quindi ha un vaso
guardandoli si vede la differenza però
nel primo
ve lo posso dire era un vaso come tutti
gli altri si notavano poche differenze
se Guardate il vaso che c'è adesso
ricoperto con una colla d'oro magari con
qualche angolino qualche imperfezione è
un vaso stupendo che per me è stupendo
perché la Nadia di ora è una Nadia
differente ma che dedica la sua vita
soprattutto agli altri
[Applauso]
[Musica]